- I love searching the
internet to find things
that may bring you joy.
This is what I'm liking.
(crashing music)
The Florida mama has three children
born on the same day.
And no, they are not triplets.
Each, it's crazy.
Each was born exactly three
years apart from the next.
Sophia on August 25th, 2015.
Giuliana on August 25th, 2018.
And their newest baby,
Mia on August 25th, 2021.
(crowd cheering)
Now I'm just doing the math.
November 25th-ish is a magical,
special time for this couple.
(audience laughing)
And I hope it's done more
than just on that night.
(crowd cheering and applauding)
That's all I'm sayin'.
We have them dialed in,
along with their girls.
So say hi to Kristin, Nick,
Sophia, Giuliana, and baby Mia.
- Hello!
- [Kelly] Hi y'all!
- Hi!
- Now this is crazy.
So Kristin,
I guess birthday planning
is pretty awesome though.
You've got it down.
It's the one day.
- I simplified it for myself, for sure.
We just, we're a big Disney family.
We met working at Disney.
So we do all the Disney themes.
Make it quite simple.
We come up with a theme.
Then we just have a big extravaganza.
- Oh my gosh, I love Disney.
That's so fun.
That's an amazing
birthday for all of them.
So Sophia, I have to ask, as big sis,
are you okay with sharing your birthday?
- Yeah, it's really cool
because instead of a little birthday
we have a big birthday.
And it's just really
cool to have two sisters
that really love me.
And it's just really awesome.
- And we told her when we had Giuliana
that she's getting a best
friend for her birthday.
And then Giuliana and Sophia
get best friends with Mia.
- Oh my gosh.
You magical little family.
That made me so happy on the inside.
Well, thank you so much for sharing.
I hope y'all have another
magical birthday at Disney.
I'm liking y'all's post right now.
And that's not all y'all.
Our season long partner,
Pilot Pen, makers of FriXion,
the go-to erasable pen of
the Kelly Clarkson Show,
want to celebrate those
creating fearlessly.
Y'all are creating
around a particular time.
And so they're gonna
give you 1,000 dollars
that y'all can use at Disney.
(crowd cheering)
- Oh my gosh!
- Wow!
- Thank you!
- I mean, I feel like you
should use some of that
for birthday fun time, is all I'm saying.
Thank you guys so much.
God Bless y'all!